a
en bolivia se han registrado más de 4600
embarazos no planificados durante la
cuarentena según datos del fondo de
naciones unidas para la población este
dato viene aparejado a varios problemas
por ejemplo el aumento de la mortalidad
materna los abortos inseguros y la baja
atención de salud para los casos de la
salud sexual y reproductiva porque los
centros de salud estaban orientados a
atender los casos de kobe 19 por otro
lado la misma entidad ha señalado que se
han registrado hasta septiembre de este
año 19 mil embarazos en niñas y
adolescentes menores de 19 años lo más
preocupante es que al menos 1000 de
estos embarazos corresponden a menores
de 14 años lo que según la ley boliviana
implica que ha habido violaciones de
estas niñas el fondo para la población
ha señalado que esto se debe a que las
niñas han permanecido encerradas con sus
agresores en las casas durante la
cuarentena
[Música]
economistas y expertos en fertilidad
están revelando que miles de mujeres
estadounidenses están evitando tener
hijos durante la pandemia por presiones
económicas derivadas del desempleo y la
falta de cobertura en la salud un
reporte del instituto brookings en
washington estima que eeuu tendrá 500
mil nacimientos - en el 2021 una
disminución del 13% en comparación con
los 3.800.000 bebés que nacieron en el
2019 la revista 'time' revela por su
parte que también desde que empezó la
pandemia hubo un aumento del 50 por
ciento de las solicitudes de píldoras
anticonceptivas y métodos de control de
natalidad se pronostica que las mujeres
latinas y las afroamericanas que más han
sufrido los efectos económicos de esta
pandemia tengan menos hijos
[Música]
australia busca aumentar su población
que es de 25 millones de habitantes para
fortalecer su economía pero la pandemia
hizo que muchas parejas se consideraran
tener un bebé algo que no ocurría desde
1930 cuando hubo la gran depresión
económica según los últimos datos
disponibles que son de 2018 la tasa de
fertilidad en australia es de 1.74 bebés
por cada mujer sin embargo expertos
advierten que esta tasa podría bajar a
1.5 debido al comic 19 por eso desde ya
australia pronostica que para 2022 habrá
en el país 600 mil personas menos de lo
que se había planeado para ese año
[Música]